as has been duly noted in the domestic
and international press this year the
board of governors of the academy of
voted the thalburg award to make the
presentation here again is former
thalburg award winner arthur freed
the irving falberg award is not
presented annually
because of its special significance few
men qualify for consideration
the qualification is based on the
cumulative excellence of motion picture
entertainment
because of his astonishing list of
artistic film successes
mr william weiler is honored for his
distinguished contributions to the art
of the cinema mr weiler
i knew irving solberg when i first came
to work at university many many years
ago
we were both very young just kids
but there was a slight difference
i was an office boy and he was already
general manager of the studio
even then and throughout his short but
distinguished career
he insisted on quality and films
and good taste
you know sparing no amount of work and
effort
in order to achieve excellence
and for this reason
i'm doubly proud and pleased to receive
this award
bearing both his name and mine
and most grateful to the board of
governors of the academy
thank you very much